you can multiply the probability of
something being shared by the average
number of people you share it with and
that will tell you how viral a piece of
content is and so with that lets us do
is have a team that comes up with lots
of creative ideas and launches things
but then have a platform that can
measure which of those things are
resonating with people and our people
sharing this and people are sharing
something at a high rate we can send
that to more people and we think sharing
is the highest bar of quality more than
a click or more than a page view if you
think something's worth sharing with
your friends that really matters and so
our technology is able to quickly detect
which things will get shared more and
let people expose people to them so that
they can enjoy them